Film Courage: Why invest all that time in
short films?
Did you realize that you were going to work
your way up to a feature film eventually?
R.L. Scott, Filmmaker: Oh yes.
Feature films was always the goal from the
beginning.
But I’ve always had a very realistic approach
to the industry.
I didn’t expect to make TRANSFORMERS like
my first week out, you know what I mean?
I always felt like it was the craft it was
really important to study it, to understand
it, to be a student of film, to take my time
and sort of get as technically skilled as
I could through studying, through courses
or through whatever it is, not be so much
in a rush to just sort of throw things out
there but really have a solid foundation and
a great understanding of all the different
aspects of filmmaking.
So most of it is to really go through the
process because you learned so much going
through the process.
Like it’s one thing to have all of these
ideas but until you really go through it and
come out the other side like you really don’t
understand it fully.
You don’t know what it takes to go from
script-to-screen and ll those little things
in-between.
And so I wanted to start from a place that
I would be comfortable, to start small.
Not be in a rush to branch out and make things
bigger.
So yes it was always in the cards to make
features but I wanted to be comfortable before
I jumped in.
And then ultimately my first feature film
I produced it myself, I didn’t ask for any
funding at all because I felt like I before
I could expect someone to invest in me I needed
to show that I invested in myself and I needed
to show the value of my work because that’s
a big thing, asking someone…asking them
to take their hard-earned money and sort of
invest in you and just looking at it from
a realistic standpoint the question would
be like “Why?
Why invest in you?
Can you even make this film?
This thing you are asking me to give you money
for can you even do it?”
You have to be able to show that you are able
of producing this thing that you are asking
people to pay you to make and so I wanted
to have a tract record of work and I wanted
a body of work that they could see.
Basically I wanted to take all of the “No’s”
away.
Like any reason they would have to say no,
I wanted to take that away from them.
And so a lot of that has to do with having
a tract record even though you haven’t had
anything distributed yet or you haven’t
had any big successes there yet to at least
have a body of work that can show consistent
growth in like and show the value of what
you have to offer I thought was important.
Film Courage: When you think back to being
in Brazil and then being in South Carolina
or somewhere in the South, how are you choosing
which films you watched when you were younger?
Like who was influencing you, was it your
Dad or your Mom?
R.L.: I think it came from martial arts and
then it came from my love of storytelling.
A lot of people think I only make action films
but I make every range of film I just happen
to love action movies because of something
I grew up watching.
But I think the martial arts was the biggest
influence but then things that had nothing
to do with action.
I just liked really smart films, thinking
man films, film that would make you think,
maybe be a little unpredictable.
Maybe the approach to telling a story is unique
or sometimes it is just how you present the
idea, sometimes it’s the way you go about
telling the story visually, there are all
of these different ways.
Even if you don’t have a lot of money you
can still make something unique.
You can still do something interesting and
different.
I think a lot of times people get too caught
up on the budget and they start to limit themselves
based on the budget.
“I don’t have enough money to do this,”
but maybe there is another way you can approach
that problem.
Or maybe there is another way to approach
telling that story that could be unique that
maybe doesn’t cost a lot.
Maybe it’s in the way you shoot it.
Maybe it’s in the way you light it.
Maybe it’s in the way you edit it.
Maybe it’s in the sound design or something
like that.
Anytime I create something I never put a constraint
on it based on the dollar amount.
I try to not think about that.
I try to think about that in terms of how
can I approach this in an artistic way or
a visually striking way or something like
that.